alors autre danger qui menace la
république le front national voilà vous
êtes carrément partisans vous de
l'interdiction à vous dites que moi je
suis honnête je vais vous dire une chose
1 je pense que la république n'est pas
un régime neutre 1 c'est un régime 15
contenu un sens politique bon quand vous
êtes un vrai démocrate vous acceptez le
faites le si vous êtes en minorité quand
les autres sont en majorité ouais vous
vous soumettez aux lois qui sont
adoptées un bien qui ici accepte qu'il
ya une majorité dans une assemblée qui
front national de se soumettre aux lois
que votre et le front national
moi je dis clairement à l'avance pas moi
donc je suis cohérent un ces camps
puisque je ne suis pas prêt à me
soumettre aux lois qu'ils adopteraient
donc je suis pour les internautes en
règle entre celles qui marquent ils
diraient pratique
voilà ce que tu dis c'est si en fait si
le front national arrive au pouvoir en
suffrage universel comme hitler était en
allemagne
moi je ne serais pas d'accord avec ce
qu'ils vont faire donc autant dire tout
de suite que je veux pas qu'il soit
autorisé parce que j'en ai assez d'être
régulièrement convoqués à aller voter
pour des gens parce que c'est mon
pouvoir démocratique on m'a volé quand
on m'appelle au 2e tour à aller voter
pour monsieur chirac avant je suis
socialiste veut simplement pour éviter
que l'autre fasse plus de voix c'est ma
liberté qui a été volé déjà ce jour là
parce que moi je n'avais pas envie de
voter pour cet homme c'est pas une
appréciation personnelle mais tous ne
comprend ce que je suis en train de dire
donc on m'a volé déjà une première fois
ma liberté je ne veux plus qu'on me l'a
volé je ne veux pas faire mon travail
était en train d'être facile on les sort
comme un épouvantail la sq intervalle
région et tout le monde soit en train de
marjah ville est en train de dire c'est
quand même que vous êtes pour le
suffrage universel
sauf quand c'est vos ennemis qui gagne
quoi pas du tout parce qu'un sens et non
écoute si c'est la droite c'est pas mes
amis je suis pas d'accord avec pas
d'accord avec leurs liens monde je suis
d'accord à crier mais là il s'agit
d'autre chose bon sens ou alors ce qu'il
sait pas autre chose d'aller le dire
avant il faut pas à chaque fois qu'il ya
une élection qui tourne mal s'amener
avec des têtes d'enterrement disant là
la catastrophe qui a danger il ya le
fascisme et outils c'est vraiment le
fascisme on se défend jean marais venant
avec kylie qui va décider aussi qui se
présente ou pas à ce moment là parce que
tout le monde peut se présenter à la
présidence
des vacances qui va des systèmes à des
mecs qui font parler d'eux quand tu as
des mecs tu as débuté à du front
national light tas de la droite un peu
dur tu as du machin tu es un peu de tout
elle est où l'escaladé mecs qui vont
vouloir réduire l'extrême gauche à ce
moment là il ya aussi des gens aussi
bien des sceaux jean-luc attend n'a rien
à voir il ya des gens à l'extrême gauche
à l'explosion de moyens je suis pas
d'accord pour obéir à des lois faites
par un mec d'extrême-gauche habitants
est interdit l'examen peut obliger de
non mais attendez moi je me suis pas en
train de faire le tour du monde je vous
parle d'un club a vu la merde j'ai
enlevé
non moi j'ai valeur a résidé après tout
c'est plutôt comment tuer le front
national s'est régalé ses fans et les
gens très sérieux parce que vous mettez
sur le même plan du tas de choses qu'on
rien à voir et vous faites comme si
c'était pareil je m'excuse arlette
laguiller le pen c'est pas pareil
mais bon moi je puis ça c'est pas moi de
dire ça je le dis c'est pas pareil pas
d'accord alors si c'est pas pareil on
n'aimait pas dans un hangar est d'accord
hbo a quand même
alors parce que j'ai dit que je veux
encore faire j'en avais d'ailleurs il a
dit de moi qu'il fallait me fusiller
donc ça va on sait très bien qu'ils ont
intérêt à moi si j'étais le jour où vous
m'aurez comme premier ministre
j'interdirais le front national a
méchamment tu envoies de la haine c'est
vrai non plus maintenant
quand on est passionné il paraît que 50
ans aurait tenté quelques essais c'est
vachement grave quand même ce que tu dis
pas ce que ça veut dire que par exemple
la question pour un artiste d'aller
jouer ou pas par exemple dans une ville
qui est front national
donc d'après si je suis ton truc à force
c'est pas compliqué toi tu y vas pas à
tant d artiste tu vas jouer le bas ou
pas je sais pas et si je les attends moi
je demande que jamais parce que dans le
dos avec même dans n'importe quel corps
humain il ya un coeur et il ya quelque
chose à allumer dedans si c'est pas si
c'est la bonne petite flamme d'amour
allait peut-être en veilleuse mais il
faut y aller
il faut y aller et donc fait ce que dira
maintien dans cette ville alors on n'y
va pas moi je sais pas je sais pas
répondre parce que j'ai tendance à
penser comme comme vous au départ en
faisant autre façon aux gars il va venir
il va la faire vibrer quelque chose de
fort mais sur le terrain il faut que tu
es ce que racontent les gens parce qu'il
ya des faux et 10 venez d'autrefois et
10 ne fait pas ça parce que vous nous
enfoncer encore plus c'est comme un tout
à part la couleur du maillot sur un
champ de bataille tu vois un mec qui va
crever j'essaye de soignies et essaye de
faire qui meurent pas et même s'il s'est
un ennemi d'hier et la tnt un toubib
était là pour sauver pour guérir
tu vois je ne sais pas touché parce
qu'il faut faire dans tous les cas nord
d'enlever à qui me concerne j'avais leur
âge c'est pour ça que je dis ce que moi
je je je ne dérogerai bien je veux
l'interdire de front national
on me dit que je n'ai pas pu poser c'est
vrai que tu poseras le couteau pour
couper je devrais savoir où tu lui poses
parce que ça va être vachement dur de
savoir où le poser mais non un peu avant
ou peu après allez ça c'est dur c'est
son truc pression pour demander de quel
signe donc il resterait que deux parties
par exemple tiens tu me rappelles une
réflexion me fais un chauffeur de taxi
un coup et j'ai trouvé très drôle
il m'a dit moi je suis tolérant mais pas
plus c'est terrifiant de décret les
rangs mais pas plus et l'errance et
tolérant
alors tu penses que j'ai tort mais je
pense que tu vas avoir du mal à
l'endroit où tu vas mettre le couteau
pour couper sait où et séoul qui va
mettre le truc c'est quand tu vas dire
non à venir par exemple le front
national veut supprimer juste front
national mais il va arriver un autre
parti arrêts qu'il a ses petites étoiles
quand on demande aux mecs pourquoi vous
n'avez pas interdit le front national 10
parce que ça va être le national front
qui va arriver de l'autre ne jamais
avoir
vous regrettez pas de pouvoir
interviewer non ça vous dit rien
annoncer ses banques c'est ainsi non
mais je vous dis juste ça comme ça parce
que là on discute en général moi je ce
que j'ai retenu de 2 g pas une vie si
j'ai en plus j'ai du [ __ ] dans une
génération où il n'y a pas eu d'immenses
drame non comme les générations d'avant
sont tapé une guerre ou des choses comme
ça mais le peu que j'ai vu ça m'a au
moins appris ça c'est que les sociétés
sont fragilisés quand elle dérape
elles vont jusqu'au bout personne
n'aurait dit que les gens les
s'entretuer en yougoslavie comme ils
l'ont fait et chaque fois pour les
salles et qu'on laisse des gens comme ça
se mettre en place
eh ben c'est la catastrophe derrière moi
j'ai pas envie de ça pour mon pays
donc comme je suis quelqu'un de
conséquent être cohérent que cherche pas
à faire plaisir mais à dire ce qui me
paraît juste pour la patrie républicaine
je le dis cela pour les accords il pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu